[Music]
dear friends I am eros chef Jewish and I
will be working for you in the area of
inter institutional relations and forset
I'm standing in the room where all
Commissioners come together to take
decisions that make Europe stronger what
will I bring to this table the world is
more challenging and more insecure just
think about the digital revolution or
climate emergency
we cannot press the pause button but we
can be better prepared for the future so
my objective is to zoom into emerging
mega trends that requires strategic
action now we need to act together so
that by 2030 Europe has a strong leading
position in the world we have what it
takes
look at the EU battery Alliance we have
anticipated the clean mobility
revolution and we acted fast to produce
the best greenest batteries and cars
here in Europe I am passionate sportsman
who believes that adversity can lead men
and women to break records
so let us roll up our sleeves and break
global records
you